Ever take you dog to the vet to get dewormed?
Yeah fun facts, humans get worms too.
Lots of them.
So what are these parasites inside us?
hey guys Julia here for DNews
Worms are some of the least loved creatures
on this planet.
From earthworms, to the parasites that live
inside of us, they just seem creepy, crawly
and slimy.
But as disgusting as they are, we’ve evolved
with them, and getting rid of them completely,
might just make us sick.
But first, let’s talk about how these parasitic
worms do harm to our bodies.
Pinworms, a small intestinal parasite, which
the Journal of Dermatology says 30-50% of
the world has, doesn’t often cause serious
illness but can cause some uncomfortable itching...when
it comes out of your anus to lay its eggs.
We get tapeworms, another intestinal parasite,
that sneaks into our bodies when we eat undercooked
beef or pork.
They cause stomach pains, nausea, and weight
loss.
Hookworms latch onto the insides of your intestines
and suck out the blood.
Which can lead to anemia, slower cognitive
growth, and malnutrition.
And whipworm, which in heavy infestations
cause intestinal problems like diarrhea and
dysentery.
Yet probably the most dreaded worm is the
nasty Guinea worm.
A worm so heinous, that President Jimmy Carter
led the fight to eliminate it in 1986.
When Carter’s quest first begin, there were
around 3.5 million cases in the world.
Last year, there were only 22.
So pretty successful campaign.
The worms typically get into your body by
drinking contaminated water.
Horrifically, the worms will later crawl out
of your skin, typically in the legs.
And it CAN TAKE DAYS TO PULL THEM OUT.
DAYS.
When leaving the body, the wounds they create
can sometimes lead to deadly infections.
So I agree with Jimmy Carter and say good
riddance to these guys.
But how do our bodies not get rid of them?
I mean, humans evolved with some of these
parasites for at least 10,000 years according
to a study published in the journal Science
Translational Medicine.
We might even have a symbiotic relationship
with them.
They scratch our backs, we scratch theirs.
Or more like, we give them a home and food
and they calm down our immune systems.
Seriously there’s evidence.
Well one study published in the journal Nature
found that some parasitic worms actually change
our immune systems.
And according to the book, “The Th2 Type
Immune Response in Health and Disease“ several
studies in mice show that parasitic worms
suppress the immune system.
They promote certain populations of regulatory
cells in the body called Tregs and B regulatory
cells.
These cells play important roles in reducing
the severity of autoimmune diseases and allergic
inflammation.
By dampening down the immune systems, the
worms won’t be attacked, while at the same
time, the mice get a break from allergies
and other autoimmune diseases.
As for how parasitic worms affect humans well,
that’s more complicated because infected
humans with parasitic worms doesn’t seem
like that fundable of a study.
But that didn’t stop one guy.
A case study published in journal Science
Translational Medicine found that one person
voluntarily infected himself with Human whipworm
and claimed it successfully treated his ulcerative
colitis.
Basically the worms lowered uncomfortable
gut inflammation and promoted mucus production,
which is important for healing.
One of the authors of the paper told NPR that
other studies suggest parasites keep the immune
system in check and “prevent it from going
wild and attacking healthy tissue.”
While that’s just one guy, another recent
study published in the Journal of Allergy
and Clinical Immunology found that hookworms
reduced the symptoms of celiac disease, another
autoimmune disease.
So while parasitic worms seem pretty nasty,
okay they are really nasty and have caused
a lot of a harm, maybe by keeping our immune
systems in check,so they can continue to live
inside of us, they actually give us a little
benefit too.
Gross.
If you don’t find it all that gross why
don’t you start your own website like wormsarentgross.com
No domain extension will help you tell your
story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.
CTA video
While I’m not going to go around popping
worm pills to treat my allergies, it does
make us stop and think.
Maybe we’re living too cleanly.
In fact that’s the premise of the hygiene
hypothesis, that figures our modern cleanliness
might be giving us allergies.
To find out more check out this episode, right
here.
So have you ever had a parasite infection?
Tell us about it down in the comments below